this is Joo podcast number 60 with Eko
Charles and me Joo willink good evening
Eko good
evening what I am about to
relate is anything but a pleasant
story in fact it is so very unpleasant
that I cannot recommend anyone without a
strong stomach to read
it for it is a story of such crime and
horror as to almost be
unbelievable the story of depredations
of a horde of degraded criminals of
incredible
beastiality on a peaceful kindly
law-abiding
people I believe it has no parallel in
modern
history and that is a
warning that was written by a man by the
name of George Fitch who was an American
in the city of Nan King China he was
working for the
YMCA in
1937 when the Imperial Japanese Army
invaded and I'm going to tell you that
that warning is not strong
enough and I know that many of you
listen to this podcast with your
children and I going to tell you right
now this
podcast this episode is not for
children this episode is barely even for
adults and I'm sure that some of you
will not make it through this
podcast
and I almost decided not to do
it this podcast this episode is going to
review a book called the rape of Nan
King by an author by the name of Iris
Chang
and part of the
reason that I decided that I had to
cover this
book is because of the
story that follows the
story and that is of Iris Chang the
author a bright beautiful intelligent
successful and loving
woman who was
[Music]
consumed by
darkness and I will discuss her fate in
a a book that was written by her mother
Ying Ying
Chang in a book called the woman who
could not
forget and what happened in the city of
Nan King
[Music]
is it is beyond
Darkness it is it is beyond
evil it
is pure savagery wanting savagery of the
highest
order
and part of me thinks maybe it's
[Music]
best if it is
forgotten maybe that's the best way to
prevent it from happening
again but part of me knows that that is
wrong and the only only way to
[Music]
learn is to study and to
understand and to try and
banish this from our memories to
me that leaves a
door leaves a door
open for something like this to happen
again
somewhere
sometime but I want to warn you
again that there are parts of this
episode that are extremely
graphic and I didn't put it all in there
but I absolutely wanted people to
understand that this is what happened
and I feel compelled to discuss
it for for one for Iris Chang who in my
mind sacrificed everything to tell this
story to help ensure that those who
suffered are
remembered and also to ensure that the
human race at
large has the knowledge has the warning
that evil
exists and that
mankind is capable of be becoming
engulfed in that
evil and that man can act without Mercy
or
remorse or the slightest shred of
humanity at
all
go to the
book to prepare for the inevitable war
with China Japan had spent decades
training its men for combat the molding
of young men to serve in the Japanese
military began early in life and in the
1930s the Marshall influence seeped into
every aspect of Japanese
Boyhood toy shops became virtual shrines
to war selling arsenals of toy soldiers
tanks helmets uniforms rifles
anti-aircraft guns Bugles and
howitzers Memoirs from that time
describe pre-adolescent boys waging mock
battles in the streets using bamboo
poles as imaginary
rifles some even tied logs of wood on
their back and fantasized about dying as
human bomb Heroes
in suicide
missions now I can tell
you I grew up doing all that stuff we
played War all the
time all the time so I I don't find
anything shocking about
that back to the book Japanese schools
operated like miniature military units
indeed some of the teachers were
Military Officers who lectured students
on their Duty on their dut to help Japan
fulfill its Divine Destiny of conquering
Asia and being able to stand up to the
world's Nations as a people Second To
None now we're starting to get off
[Music]
course they taught young boys how to
handle wooden models of guns and older
boys how to handle real ones textbooks
became vehicles for military propaganda
one geography book even used the shape
of Japan as justif ification for
expansion we appear to be standing in
the Vanguard of Asia advancing bravely
into the Pacific at the same time we
appear ready to defend the Asian
continent from outside
attack teachers also instilled in boy
hatred and contempt for the Chinese
people preparing them psychologically
for a future invasion of the Chinese
Mainland one historian tells the story
of a squeamish Japanese school boy in
the 1930s who burst into tears when told
to dissect a frog his teacher slammed
his knuckles against the boy's head and
yelled why are you crying about one
lousy frog when you grow up you'll have
to kill 100 200
chinks Japanese minister of Education
declared that schools were run not for
the benefit of the students but for the
good of the
country elementary school School
teachers were trained like military
recruits with student teachers housed in
barracks and subject to harsh discipline
and
indoctrination in
1890 the Imperial rescript on education
emerged it laid down a code of ethics to
govern not only students and teachers
but every Japanese
citizen the rescript was the civilian
equivalent of Japanese military codes
which valued above all obedience to
Authority
and unconditional loyalty to the
emperor in every Japanese school a copy
of the rescript was enshrined with a
portrait of the emperor and taken out
each morning to be
read it was reputed that more than one
teacher who accidentally stumbled over
the wards committed suicide to atone for
the insult to the sacred
document so we've got a that's 1890 by
the way 1890 so this is Generation now
that this is being plugged into the to
the students
brains and these
things you know when when we when we
talk about students we talk about
children we teach them
generally freedom is the ultimate goal
freedom is the
ultimate the
ultimate the ultimate thing to strive
for the ultimate thing to defend is
freedom and here they're getting taught
that the ultimate thing was obedience to
Authority and unconditional
loyalty back to the book it was common
place for teachers to behave like
sadistic drill sergeant slapping
children across the cheeks hitting them
with their fists or bludgeoning them
with bamboo or wooden swords students
were forced to hold heavy heavy objects
sit on their knees stand Barefoot in the
snow or run around around the playground
until they collapsed from
exhaustion there were certainly few
visits to the schools by indignant or
even concerned parents the pressure to
confirm to Authority intensified if the
school boy decided to become a
soldier vicious hazing and Relentless
and Relentless pecking order usually
squelched any residual Spirit of
individualism within him obedience was
touted as a supreme
virtue and a sense of individual
self-worth was replaced by a sense of
value as a small Cog in the larger
scheme of
things to establish the sublimation of
individuality to the common good
Superior officers of older soldiers
slapped recruits for almost no reason at
all or beat them severely with Heaven
wooden rod heavy wooden
rods according to the author toshio
officers often Justified unauthorized
punishment saying I do not beat you
because I hate you you I beat you
because I care for you do you think I
perform these acts with hands swollen
and bloody in a state of
Madness some youths died under such
brutal physical conditions others
committed
suicide the majority became tempered
vessels into which the military could
pour a new set of life
goals so this is complete you know
militant raising of children and what I
want to note here
is anybody that thinks you know what
that probably produced some incredible
Warriors you're actually
wrong did it did it produce Warriors yes
it did but let's let's
remember that these Warriors that were
raised in this manner when they
had American soldiers and marines that
had to face them when they were in
incredibly well dug in defensive
positions and the Americans had to take
beat Beach fronts and Beach
heads the freethinking American Soldier
proved to be the
better back to the book training was no
less grueling a process for aspiring
officers above all the Japanese Cadets
were to adop adopt a will which knows no
defeat so terrified were the cadets of
any hint of failure that examination
results were kept secret to minimize the
risk of
suicide so that's what again this was
this was going all the way back to 1890
so we've got 40 50 years worth before we
we get into this where this uh Massacre
takes
place back to the book in the summer of
1937 Japan finally succeeded in
provoking a fullscale war with China so
Japan was now engaging in a war with
China they went to Shang High the
Japanese invaded Shanghai you know big
giant City and they they thought they
were going to have no Factor right
because they're getting told all the
time that they're the best and they're
the there's they're you the Supreme
Warriors and all this well going back to
the book here Japanese military military
leaders had boasted and seriously
believed that Japan could conquer all of
mainland China within three months we
got some arrogance going on here but
when a battle in a single Chinese city
alone that was Shanghai dragged from
Summer to fall and then from fall to
winter it shattered Japanese fantasies
of an easy Victory here this primitive
people illiterate in military science
and poorly trained had managed to fight
the superior Japanese to a stand still
when Shanghai finally fell in November
the mood of the Imperial troops had
turned
ugly and many say and many it was said
lusted for Revenge as they March towards
Nan
King so they're on route now they had a
hard time taking down Shanghai they got
Vengeance on their mind when they're
going into the city of Nan King back to
the book little was spared on the path
to Nan King Japanese veterans remember
raiding Tiny Farm communities where they
clubbed or bayonetted everyone in
sight but small villages were not the
only casualties entire cities were
raised to the ground
consider the example of sucha a city on
the East Bank of Tai Lake one of the
oldest cities in China it was prized for
its delicate silk embroidery palaces and
Temple temples its canals and ancient
Bridges had earned its earned the city
its Western nickname as the Venice of
China on November 19th on a morning of
pouring rain a Japanese Advanced guard
marched through the gates of such Chia
wearing hoods that prevented the Chinese
centuries from recognizing them once
inside the Japanese murdered and
plundered the city for days burning down
ancient landmarks and abducting
thousands of Chinese women for sexual
slavery The Invasion according to the
China weekly review caused the
population of the city to drop from
350,000 to less than
but the worst was still to come now
there was a a general that was sort of
in charge of the the Japanese that were
heading to to Nan King his name was
General
Matsui and he seemed to have some
semblance of honor to
him and gave
some pretty pretty good I would say
benevolent type as benevolent as you can
be when you're going into war of orders
so here's one of the things that he
proclaimed the back to the book the
entry of the Imperial Army into a
foreign capital is a great event in our
history attracting the attention of the
world therefore let no unit enter the
city in a disorderly fashion let them
know beforehand the Matters To Be
Remembered and the position of foreign
rights and interests in the walled City
let them be absolutely free from
Plunder he's given some pretty
like I said about as benevolent orders
as you could give that was Matsui well
unfortunately Matsui gets
sick and he can't be the leader although
he kind of goes in and out of a
leadership position as this is going on
there's a new guy that comes in and the
new guy that comes is his actual
royalty named Prince
Asaka now brce Prince Asaka gets word he
starts to get to understand the
situation that they're going into and he
gets told that yeah they're going to be
when they take Nan King they're going to
have about
300,000 Chinese troops to deal
with and they get some preliminary
word that it sounds like that the
Chinese are ready to surrender they kind
of hear that intelligence they have
spies in there and whatnot back to the
book after Asaka heard this report it
was said that his headquarters sent out
a set of orders under his personal seal
marked secret to be
destroyed we now know that the message
of these orders was
clear kill all
captives and they actually do have a
copy of an order that came
out and this was on December 13th 1937
the Japanese 66th Battalion received the
following command I'm not going to read
the whole thing but here's parts of it
Battalion battle reporter at0 at two
0000 received order from the regiment
Commander to comply with or orders from
the Brigade commanding headquarters all
prisoners of War are to be executed
method of execution divide the prisoners
into a group of a dozen shoot to kill
separately goes on to give some details
about who's supposed to run this and
then it continues back to the book the
vicinity of the imprisonment must be
heavily guarded our intentions are
absolutely not to be detected by the
prisoners every company is to complete
preparation before 0500 executions are
to start start promptly by that time an
action is to be finished by
7:30 so there you go straight up orders
they're going to kill
everyone and it's very important to note
here they says our intentions are
absolutely not to be detected so they
were going to make it very clandestine
and keep the the Chinese from knowing
that they were going to kill them
all back to the book there was a
ruthless logic to the order the captives
could not be fed so they had to be
destroyed killing them would not only
eliminate the food problem but diminish
the possibility of
retaliation moreover dead enemies could
not form up into Guerilla
forces so they have their orders they go
in and begin the operation
and here we go back to the book all this
was easier to achieve than the Japanese
had anti anti had
anticipated resistance was sporadic
indeed it was practically
non-existent having thrown away their
arms when attempting to flee the city as
the Japanese closed in many Chinese
soldiers simply turned themselves in
hoping for better
treatment once the men surrendered and
permitted their hands to be
bound the rest was
easy so the Chinese give up their
weapons and allow themselves to be
taken not a good
idea now we're going to
go to a quote from a Japanese
soldier named auma it was funny yet
pable when I imag imagined how they
gathered whatever white cloth they could
find attached it to a dead twig and
marched forward just to
surrender I thought how could they
become prisoners with the kind of force
that they had more than two battalions
and even without trying to show any
resistance there must have been a
considerable number of officers for this
many troops but not a single one
remained all of them having slipped away
and escaped I thought although we had
two companies IES and those 7,000
prisoners had already been disarmed our
troops could have been annihilated had
they decided to rise up and
Revolt and I didn't go through too much
of this but it was a chaotic scene when
the Chinese realized what was going to
happen and as that indicated a lot of
the senior leadership they fled the city
and so it left these soldiers there now
with no leadership and what are they
going to do and you know the Japanese
did psychological warfare on them and
Dro leaflets that said hey if you
surrender you'll be treated well we have
rice for you and that's what they did
they lied of
course back to the book when the
Japanese military received orders on
December 17th to kill prisoners they
proceeded with extra caution that
morning the Japanese announced that they
were going to transport the Chinese
prisoners to a small island in the m in
the middle of the yansi river they
explained to the captives that they
needed to take special precautions to
move for the move and bound the captives
hands behind their backs a task that
took all morning and most of the
afternoon sometime between 4: and 6:00
p.m. the Japanese divided the prisoners
into four columns and marched them to
the West skirting the hills and stopping
at the
riverbank after three or 4 hours of
waiting and not knowing what was going
on the prisoners could not see any
preparations for crossing the
river the Corporal wrote it was going
dark they did not know that Japanese
soldiers already encircled them in a
crescent formation along the river and
that they were in sights of many machine
guns by the time the exe by the time the
executions began it was too late for the
Chinese to
escape suddenly all kinds of guns fired
at
once kha RI wrote
the sound of the Firearms mingled with
the desperate yelling and
screams for an hour the chines struggled
and thrashed about desperately until
there were few sounds coming from the
group from evening until dawn the
Japanese bayonetted the bodies one by
one and that scene took place over over
and over and over again cuz what they
did as they indicated and then that in
that order if you missed it they
separated the groups so they had them
captured inside the city and then they
took them in small units of 30 40
Chinese soldiers tied their hands and
said yep we're going to transport you
and they did this all over the city at
the same time coordinated and then took
them out to different places outside the
city and killed
them but it wasn't only the soldiers
that they did this
to back to the book after the soldiers
surrendered on mass there was virtually
no one left to protect the citizens of
the city knowing this the Japanese
poured into Nan King on December 13th
1937 occupying government buildings
Banks and warehouses shooting people
randomly in the streets many of them in
the back as they ran
away using machine guns revolvers and
rifles the Japanese fired at the crowds
of wounded soldiers elderly women and
children who gathered in the North and
Central roads and nearby alleys they
also killed Chinese civilians in every
section of the city tiny Lanes major
boulevards mud dugouts government
buildings City
squares as victims toppled to the ground
moaning and screaming the streets alleys
and ditches of the Fallen Capital ran
rivers of blood much of it coming from
people barely alive with no strength
left to run
away
the Japanese systematically killed the
city dwellers as they conducted hous to-
house searches for Chinese soldiers and
Nan
King but they also massacred the Chinese
in nearby suburbs and Countryside
corpses piled up outside the city walls
along the river by ponds and lakes and
on hills and
mountains in villages near Nan King the
Japanese shot down any young man who
passed under the presumption that he was
likely to be a former Chinese
Soldier but they also murdered people
who could not possibly be Chinese
soldiers elderly men and women for
instance if they hesitated or even if
they failed to understand orders which
were delivered in Japanese
language and obviously not every Chinese
person spoke
Japanese so this is now just a full-on
killing
spree and I'm going to read a section
here there was there was military war
correspondents that were there from the
Japanese
military and I will read this one is
from a a military war correspondent
named Yukio
omata and he saw the Chinese uh
prisoners being brought and lined up
along the
river back to the
book those in the first row were
beheaded those in the second row were
forced to dump the severed bodies into
the river before they themselves were
beheaded The Killing went on non-stop
from morning until night but they were
only able to kill 2,000 persons in this
way the next day tired of killing in
this fashion they set up machine guns
two of them raak a crossfire at the
lined up prisoners rat tat tat tat
triggers were pulled the prisoners fled
into the water but no one was able to
make it to the other
Shore systematic
murder of everyone is basically what
we're dealing
with and when they got their momentum
going on the extermination of most of
the
men they turned their attention to the
women back to the book women suffered
the
most takuro kosu a former soldier in the
114th division of the Japanese Army in
Nang King
recalled no matter how young or
old they all could not Escape the Fate
of being
raped we sent out coal trucks to the
city streets and villages to seize a lot
of women and then each of them was
allocated to 15 to 20 soldiers for
sexual intercourse and
abuse surviving Japanese veterans claim
that they that the Army had officially
outlawed rape of enemy women but rape
remained so deeply embedded in Japanese
military culture and Superstition that
no one took the rule
seriously many believed that raping
virgins would make them more powerful in
battle soldiers were even known to wear
amulets made from the pubic hair of such
victims believing that they possessed
magical powers against
injury the military policy forbidding
rape only encouraged soldiers to kill
their victims
afterwards during an interview for the
documentary in the name of the emperor
auma Shiro a former Japanese soldier
spoke candidly about the process of rape
and murder in Nan
King we took turns raping them it would
be all right if we only raped them I
shouldn't say all right but we always
stabbed and killed them because dead
bodies don't
talk takak Coro Koo shared auma
bluntness in discussing the issue after
raping we would also kill them he
recalled these women would start to flee
once we let them go then we would bang
shoot them in the back and finish them
up according to surviving veterans many
of the soldiers felt remarkably little
guilt about
this perhaps when we were raping her we
looked at her as a woman auma wrote but
when we killed her we just thought of
her as something like a
pig
so where where is this mindset comes
from that permits this kind of
behavior I'm going to the book the
Japanese soldier was not simply hardened
for battle in China he was hardened for
the task of murdering Chinese combatants
and non-combatants
alike indeed various games and exercises
were set up by the
Japanese military to numb its men to the
human instinct against killing people
who are not
attacking for example on the way to the
capital Japanese soldiers were made to
participate in killing competitions
which were avidly covered by the
Japanese media like sporting
events the most notorious one appeared
in the December 7th issue of the Japan
advisor under the headline sub
lieutenants race to fell 100 Chinese
running close
contest subl lieutenant mukai toshiaki
and sub liutenant NOA
[Music]
teishi they were in a contest friendly
contest to see which one of them will
first fell 100 Chinese
individuals individual sword
combat before the Japanese forces
completely occupy Nan
King they're well in the Final Phase of
their race running almost neck to
neck on Sunday December 5th the score
according to Ash asai was subl liutenant
mukai 89 and sub liutenant NOA
78 and just to give some more context on
this these were just lining people up
and chopping their heads off that's what
this was just lining up civilians and
let's see who can get to 150 or 100
first back to the book a week later the
paper reported that neither man could
decide who had pass the 100 Mark first
so they U the gold to
150 makai's blade was slightly damaged
in the competition the Japan adviser
reported he explained that this was the
result of cutting a Chinese in half
helmet and
all the contest was fun
he
declared another Japanese soldier
talking
about his
experience Tom Naga shoo wrote we made
them like this good Sons good daddies
good Elder Brothers at home were brought
to the front to kill each
other human beings turned into murdering
Dem
demons everyone became a demon within 3
months in interview after interview japa
Japanese veterans from the Nang King M
Massacre reported honestly that they
experienced a complete lack of remorse
or sense of wrongdoing even when
torturing helpless
civilians nagatomi hakudo spoke candidly
about his emotions in the Fallen
Capital quote I remember being driven in
a truck along a path that had been
cleared through piles of thousands and
thousands of slaughtered
bodies wild dogs were gnawing at the
dead flesh as we stopped and pulled a
group of Chinese prisoners out of the
back then the Japanese officer proposed
a test of my courage he un sheathed his
sword spat on it and with a sudden
Mighty swing he brought it down on the
neck of a Chinese boy cowering before
us the head was cut clean off and
tumbled away on the group as the body
slumped
forward blood spurting out in two great
gushing fountains from the
neck the officer suggested I'd take the
head home as a
suvenir I remember smiling proudly as I
took his sword and began killing
people few know that soldiers impaled
babies on bayonets and toss them still
alive into pots of boiling
water they ganged raped women from ages
of 12 to 80 and then killed them when
they could no longer satisfy sexual
requirements I beheaded people starved
them to death burned them and buried
them alive over 200 in
all it is terrible that I could turn
into an animal and do these
things there are really no words to
explain what I was
doing I was truly a
devil Beyond
those situations torture was
also completely
common and here's what the book says the
torture that the Japanese inflicted upon
the native population at Nan King almost
suppresses supasses the limits of human
comprehension here are only a few
examples live burials the Japanese
directed burial operations with the
Precision and efficiency of an assembly
line soldiers would force one group of
Chinese captives to dig a grave a second
group to bury the first and then a third
group to bury the second and so on some
victims were partially buried to their
chest or necks so they would endure
further Agony such as being hacked to
Pieces by swords or run over by horses
and
tanks mutilation the Japanese not only
disemboweled decapitated and dismembered
victims but performed more excruciating
varieties of torture throughout the city
they nailed prisoners to Wood and boards
and ran over them with tanks crucified
them to trees and electrical posts
carved long strips of Flesh from them
and used them for bayonet practice at
least 100 men reportedly had their eyes
gouged out and their noses and ears
hacked off before being set on
fire another group of 200 Chinese
soldiers and civilians were stripped
naked tied columns and doors of a school
and then stabbed by special needles with
handles on them in hundreds of points
along their bodies including their
mouths throats and
eyes death by
fire the Japanese subjected large crowds
of victims to mass
incineration a Japanese soldier bound
Chinese captives together 10 at a time
and pushed them into a pit where there
was was sprayed with gasoline and
ignited on taping Road the Japanese
ordered a large number of shop clerks to
extinguish a fire then bound them
together with rope and threw them into
the
blaze Japanese soldiers even devised
games with
fire one method of entertainment was to
drive mobs of Chinese to the top stories
or roofs of buildings tear down the
stairs and then set the bottom floors on
fire many such victims committed suicide
by jumping out of Windows or off
rooftops another form of amusement
involved dousing victims in fuel
shooting them and watching them explode
into
flame in one Infamous incident Japanese
soldiers forced hundreds of men women
and children into a square soaked them
with gasoline and then fired on them
with machine
guns death by Ice thousands of victims
were intentionally frozen to death
during the rape of Nan King for instance
Japanese soldiers forced hundreds of
Chinese prisoners to March to the edge
of a frozen pond where they were ordered
to strip naked break the ice and Plunge
in the water to go
fishing their bodies hardened into
floating targets that were immediately
riddled with Japanese
bullets in another incident the Japanese
tied up a group of refugees flung them
into a shallow Pond and bombarded them
with hang grenades causing an explosive
shower of blood and
flesh death by dogs one diabolical means
of torture was to bury victims to their
waist and watch them get ripped apart by
German
Shepherds Witnesses saw Japanese
soldiers strip a victim naked and direct
German Shepherds to bite sensitive areas
of his
body the dogs not only ripped open his
belly but jerked out his intestines
along the ground for a
distance the incidents mentioned above
are only a fraction of the methods that
the Japanese used to torment their
victims the Japanese saturated victims
in acid impaled babies with bayonets
hung people by their
tongues one Japanese reporter who later
investigated the rape of Nang King
learned that at least one Japanese
soldier tore the heart and liver out of
a Chinese victim to eat
them even genitals apparently were
consumed a Chinese soldier who escaped
from Japanese custody saw several dead
people in the streets with their penises
cut
off he was later told that the penises
were sold to Japanese customers who
belied that eating them would increase
vertil
with regards
to the fate of the
women they don't know how to determine
the exact number of the women that were
raped in Nan
King but they do know that it was
almost
Universal back to the book the Japanese
raped Nang King women from all classes
Farm wives students teachers white
collar and blue collar workers wives of
YMCA employees University professors
even Buddhist nuns some of whom were
gang raped to
death and they were systematic in their
recruitment of women and Nan King
Japanese soldiers searched for them
constantly as as they looted homes and
dragged men off for
execution some actually conducted doorto
door searches demanding money and young
girls Chinese women were raped in all
locations and at all
hours an estimated onethird of all rapes
occurred during the
day survivors even remember soldiers
prying open in the legs of victims to
rape them in broad daylight in the
middle of the street and in front of
crowds of
witnesses no place was too sacred for
rape the Japanese attacked women in
naries churches and Bible training
schools 17 soldiers raped one woman in
succession in a seminary
compound old age was no concern to the
Japanese matrons grandmothers and
great-grandmothers endured repeated
sexual assaults
a Japanese soldier who raped a woman of
60 was ordered to clean the penis by her
mouth when a woman of 62 protested to
soldiers that was she was too old for
sex they rammed a stick up inside her
instead many women in their 80s were
raped to death and at least one woman in
that age group was shot and killed
because she refused a Japanese solders
advances
if the Japanese treatment of old women
was terrible their treatment of young
children was
Unthinkable little girls were raped so
brutally that some could not walk for
weeks
afterwards many required surgery others
died Chinese Witnesses saw Japanese rape
girls under 10 years of age in the
streets and then slash them in half by
sword in some cases the Japanese sliced
open the vaginas of pre-teen girls in
order to Ravish them more
effectively
even in advanced stages of
pregnancy did not render women immune to
assault the Japanese violated many who
were about to go into labor were in
labor or who had given birth only a few
days
earlier one victim who is 9 months
pregnant was raped suffered not only
still birth but a complete mental
collapse at least one pregnant woman was
kicked to
death still more gruesome was the
treatment allotted to some of the unborn
children of these
women after gang rape Japanese soldiers
sometimes slashed open the bellies of
pregnant women and ripped out the
fetuses for
amusement
during the mass rape the Japanese
destroyed children and infants often
because they were in the
way eyewitness's
report describe children and babies
suffocating from clothes stuffed in
their mouths or bayoneted to death
because they wept as their mothers were
being
raped American and European observers of
the rape of n King recorded numerous
entries like this
one February 3rd about 5:00 p.m. at
changu Zang three soldiers came and
forced a woman to throw away her baby
after raping her they went away
laughing
perhaps one of the most brutal forms of
Japanese entertainment was the
impalement of
vaginas in the streets of Nan King
corpses of women lay with their legs SPL
open their orifice pierced by wooden
rods twigs and
weeds it is painful almost mind-numbing
to contemplate some of the other objects
that were used to to torment the Nan
King women who suffered almost
unendurable
ordeals for instance one Japanese
soldier who raped a young woman thrust a
beer bottle into her and shot
her another raped victim was found with
a golf stick rammed into
her and on December 22nd in a
neighborhood near the Gate of tonging
men the Japanese raped a Barber's wife
and then stuck a firecracker in her
vagina it blew up and killed
her not all the victims were
women Chinese men were often sodomized
or forced to perform a variety of
repulsive sexual acts in front of
laughing Chinese soldiers or Japanese
soldiers at least one Chinese man was
murdered because he refused to commit
necrofilia with the corpse of a woman in
the snow
the Japanese also delighted in trying to
coorse men who had taken lifetime vows
of celibacy to engage in sexual
intercourse a Chinese woman had tried to
disguise herself as a man trying to pass
through the gates of Nang King but
Japanese guards who systematically
searched all passing pedestrians by
groping at their crotches discovered her
true
sex gang raped followed at which time a
Buddhist monk had the misfortune to
Venture near the scene the Japanese
tried to force him to have sex with a
woman they had just
raped when the monk Pro protested they
castrated him causing the poor man to
bleed to
death some of the most sorid instances
of sexual torture involved the
degradation of entire
families the Japanese Drew sadistic
pleasure in forcing Chinese men to
commit incest fathers to rape their own
daughters Brothers their sisters Sons
their
mothers a Chinese Battalion Commander
stranded in Nang King for 3 months after
the city fell saw or heard of at least
four or five instances in which the
Japanese ordered Sons to rape their
mothers those who refused were killed on
the
spot his report is substantiated by the
testimony of a German Diplomat who
reported that one Chinese man who
refused to rape his own mother was
killed with saber strokes and his mother
committed suicide shortly
thereafter those who defied the Japanese
were often found later with their eyes
torn out their noses ears and breasts
cut
off
as I
said this is pure
evil
and I don't know what else to
say
now I'm going to the book here it's hard
to talk about a bright spot in the
horror that is the rape of Nan King but
if one one canid is surely to shine a
light on the actions of a small band of
Americans and Europeans who risked their
lives to defy the Japanese Invaders and
rescue hundreds of thousands of Chinese
refugees from almost certain
extermination the courageous men and
women created the international
committee for the Nan King safety zone
so this
is you know amongst obviously this just
most sadistic and heinous
evil there were some Americans and some
Europeans that lived and worked in Nan
King and you got to remember this is
1937 so it wasn't a World War yet the
there was Germans there in Nan in Nan
King there was Americans there in Nan
King and when this started to happen
there was several of them who basically
formed an area which said you know this
is a safe
Zone and one of them interestingly
was a German and was a
Nazi so there's a Nazi who they ended up
calling the living Buddha of Nan
King and
so this this
individual um John
RAB
was he risked his life to set up this
this safety zone and actually you know
he was a he was a like I said he was a
Nazi but he had spent so much time in
Nan King and he had all these Chinese
friends and you know according to this
to the background on him you know he's
there in 19 he's been there for many
years and I don't know what year he got
there but he's not familiar with what's
going on with the actual Nazi party back
in Germany he's disconnected I mean
there's you know this is whatever
there's no internet he's not watching TV
he doesn't know what's going on so he
was just sort of sort of there and oh
The prominent party in Germany is the
Nazi party oh and I'm a diplomat so I
guess I'm a Nazi
and but when he you know he sounded like
he was a a guy that was a benevolent guy
and he actually went out into town and
and literally stopped rapes from
happening himself and what's interesting
is and this this to me set up that you
could see what they thought of the
Chinese people is that all he would do
is go out and be like stop and he he had
the Nazi armband or what he had Nazi he
had the the swastika and when they saw
that they would listen to him and so I
mean so like he was a white guy and they
they clearly listened to him and were
kind of afraid of him and yet you know
obviously they had zero less than zero
respect for the Chinese
people
and so so he actually wrote a letter as
well to Hitler explaining what was going
on and you know there's there's no one
knows if Hitler actually ever read it it
sounds like he read it and ignored it
but one of the most interesting
important pieces of what John Rabe did
is he he kept a journal a detailed
Journal of what had happened so a lot of
the stuff that that I just quoted which
I know is is horrible he was the guy
he's one of the people that that wrote
it down and made sure that that it was
going to be recorded and actually the
the that diary didn't get really
discovered and
uncovered until much later until really
and and um Iris Chang is the one that
sort of popularized and and took this
journal and made it into a real document
that explained what had happened there
so that's you know again this this John
RAB you know let's
let's even in all that Darkness there
was people that stepped up and spoke
against it another one was a guy by the
name of Robert
[Music]
Wilson and he was actually grew up in
Nan King and he was a Methodist
missionary but he had then left Nan King
and gone back to America he went to
Princeton and then he went to Harvard
Medical School and when he got done with
all of his schooling instead of staying
in America he went back to Nan King to
become a surgeon in Nan King and he was
him along with John RAB these were the
guys that went out and set up this
protective Zone and did all kinds of you
know it's it's sort of like a Shindler
list scenario know they were helping
soldiers get rid of their papers and
give them clothes they didn't look like
Chinese soldiers Sheltering the women
bringing setting up uh places where the
women could hide in the attics of the
buildings that's what they were doing
and it's the only thing that's well I
guess it's not different but you know
it's different in the fact that they
could get away with it because we
weren't at war with the
Japanese and so this guy Wilson was was
a surgeon So Not only was he trying to
protect tech people he was doing surgery
on them all the time trying to get them
to trying to save them from these
devastating wounds that they
had he also kept a a really detailed
diary which again these these and this
is you know part of the
whole kind of Genesis of this book is
that and I'll get to this later
but the you know you've heard of like
Holocaust deniers oh the Holocaust
didn't happen well it's the same thing
with this event people say oh it wasn't
that bad you know it wasn't that big of
a deal that you know there was some
killing so there was people that said
that you know some Japanese nationalist
that said oh that didn't it wasn't
really that bad it was provoked or
whatever they're going to say and these
documents these these documents that
corroborated all this information were
truly
important going back to the book here
one of the worst scenes Nelson saw
Wilson saw Nan King a scene he would
remember for the rest of his life
massive gang of a massive gang rape of
teenage girls in the street a group of
young women between the ages of 15 and
18 were lined up by Japanese and then
raped in the dirt one after the other by
an entire
regiment some hinged and died while
others killed themselves shortly
afterwards but the scenes in the
hospitals were even more horrifying than
those in the streets Wilson was
mortified by the women who came to the
emergency room with their bellies ripped
open by the charred and horribly
disinger men whom the Japanese tried to
burn alive and by numerous other Horrors
he had barely had time to describe on
paper he told his wife that he would
never forget a woman whose head was
nearly cut off teetering from a point on
her
neck the morning came this morning and
this is quote this morning another woman
came in a sad plight and with a terrible
story story a Hospital volunteer wrote
of this woman in his diary in January
3rd
1938 she was one of the five women whom
the Japanese soldier had taken to one of
their medical units to wash their
clothes by day and be raped by night two
of them were forced the two of them were
forced to satisfy from 15 to 20 men and
the prettiest one as much as 40 each
night this one who came to us had been
called off by three soldiers into an
isolated place where they attempted to
cut off her head the muscles of the neck
had been cut but they failed to sever
the spinal cord she feigned death but
dragged herself to the hospital another
of the many to Bear witness to the
brutality of the
soldiers so Wilson just saw complete
Horrors then back to the book he
operated for free because few patients
had money to pay him but the surgeries
exacted a terrible price on his own
health in the end his family believes
that the only his faith as a devout
Methodist combined with his love for
China gave him the courage to survive
the rape of Nan
King another one of these Europeans in
this case American a Westerner I should
say
was VH helina votan or minivan as they
called
her as by occupation head of the
education department dean of studies at
ginling Women's Arts and Science College
was one of the few Western women in the
city during the first few weeks of the
Nan King Massacre years later she would
be remembered not only for her courage
in protecting thousands of women from
Japanese soldier but also for the diary
she kept a diary that some historians
believe will eventually be recognized
much like the Diary of Anne Frank for
its importance in Illuminating the
spirit of a single witness during the
Holocaust of
war vren the daughter of a blacksmith
was 51 years old in 1937 raised in the
tiny farming community of seor
Illinois she went to live with neighbors
when her mother died despite the
improvment of her childhood she was able
to work her way through school
graduating with honors in 1912 from the
University of Illinois at arban arbana
champagne so just again a a Westerner in
this case an
American and she had the opportunity to
maybe Escape but she stayed in Nan King
back to the book with most of the
faculty gone from Nan King most had
abandoned their homes to flee to cities
like Shanghai shenu and
sheshan votan was now the acting head of
the institution she labored to prepare
for the campus for female refugees and
to evacuate wounded soldiers from the
area to disguise their identity she
burned their military papers and
garments in the college incinerator
under her Direction Furniture was moved
into attics safes were emptied dorms
were cleaned and valuables were wrapped
in oil paper and hidden meanwhile
posters signs and armbands for the na
nan King safety zone were created and
distributed among the volunteers
here's talking about a specific day the
following day December 17th 1937 was
even worse the migration of women into
ginling only intensified as the Japanese
soldiers flooded the city what a
heartbreaking sight Votran wrote weary
women frightened girls trudging with
children and bedding in small packages
of
clothes if only someone had time to
write the story of each Refugee who came
in she thought especially the stories of
the girls who had blackened their faces
and cut their hair as she accommodated
the stream of wild-eyed women she heard
stories of Japanese raping girls as
young as 12 and women as elderly as 60
or raping pregnant women at Bayonet
Point
and
the sick and depraved and disgusting and
horrific stories go on and on and on and
the brutality page after page after page
of diary entries in
quotes and witness
accounts and then
pictures there is pictures in the
book the pictures of severed heads and
Chinese bound to poles being bayonetted
to death and pictures of others being
beheaded and pictures of giant pits
filled with bodies and images of
hundreds and hundreds of bodies and
entangled masses on the banks of the
yangi
river
[Music]
it's
it's it's too much for the mind to
comprehend it really is it's almost too
much to
understand and so what we
do is we package it all
up right and we give it a name a
massacre or an
atrocity and I'm sure sure you could
tell I mean even as I'm sitting here
reading this I'm gone I'm just
numb but
[Music]
we have to remember that every one of
those
people tortured raped and killed was a
person a person like your brother or
like your sister or like your mom or
like your
dad or a person like your son or your
daughter a
person like
you and maybe you can get a hold of
that but what's in some way is even
harder to
grasp is the Japanese
soldiers that they were
people and yes they were certainly
monsters
vile and Despicable and completely
devoid of feelings but even so even
though they were
monsters
they were human
monsters and They too had Mothers and
Fathers and Sons and Daughters and yet
they
did
[Music]
this and the fact that what happened at
Nan King was so brutal and so Beyond
comparison with anything that ever
happened was one of the things that
almost caused it to be
forgotten and that
that Supreme level of
brutality lasted about 6 weeks and
eventually that morphed into an
occupation of Nan King by the Japanese
and they ruled with an iron fist of
course and they stole and they plundered
and they abused locals and they
continued to to
rape which they actually institutional
institutionalized and and eventually
became you've heard the term Comfort
women and they gave out opium freely to
ensave people just like happens in this
day and age people become slaves to
drugs
and it stayed in that occupied state
for about 8 years
until finally almost as quickly as it
began it
ended I'm going back to the
book the end of Nan King's ordeal came
in the last came at last in the summer
of 1945
on August 6th 1945 the United States
dropped an untested uranium bomb on
Hiroshima Japan's eighth largest city
killing 100,000 of its 245 people
245,000 people on the first
day when a Japanese surrender was not
forthcoming the Americans dropped on
August 9th a second plutonium type bomb
on the Japanese city of Nagasaki
less than a week later on August 14th
the Japanese made the final decision to
surrender the Japanese remained in the
former capital of China until the day of
the surrender then quickly left the city
eyewitnesses reported that Japanese
soldier could be seen drinking heavily
or weeping in the streets some heard
rumors of unarmed Japanese men being
forced to kneel by the side of the road
to be beaten by local residents
retaliation against the Japanese
Garrison appears to be to have been
limited however because many residents
hid at home during this chaotic time too
fearful to even celebrate the news of a
Japanese
defeat the evacuation was Swift and
there was no Mass persecution or
imprisonment of Japanese
soldiers one Nan King resident recalls
that she stayed in her house for weeks
after the Japanese surrendered and when
she
reemerged they were
gone and so it was
over and there
were work some some level of War crime
trials and there were some
executions mainly of the highest profile
officers Prince Asaka who had given that
order to kill all
captives he avoided Pro prosecution the
scale of the massacre was downplayed and
the reason that there's a bunch of
reasons of why the scale of the rape of
Nan King got downplayed one of them
being that the Now Chinese communist
state was actually trying to build
relationships with post-war
Japan
so the massacre was quietly buried and
now you had the Chinese people were now
in a communist state and there wasn't
much speaking out to to
do and the Japanese downplayed the
[Music]
horrors as saying it was uh you know
just another incident of
war and some Japanese officials were
quoted as saying it's a story made up by
the Chinese it it's tarnished the image
of Japan but it was a
lie and they said things like I think
the Nan King Massacre is a
Lie the women that were raped were
labeled as comfort women and licensed
prostitutes and many Japanese officials
say that what happened in Nan King was
just a part of
war and there's a really clear example
of
downplaying not only the rape of Nan
King but of the war in general and they
put this some of this in the
book and they're talking about the the
Japanese
education system here we go back to the
book the Japanese the entire Japanese
education system suffers from selective
amnesia for not until
1994 were Japanese school children
taught that Hiro's Army was responsible
for the deaths of at least 20 million
Allied soldiers and Asian civilians
during World War
II in the n in the early 1990s a
newspaper article quoted a Japanese High
School teacher who claimed that his
students were surprised to learn that
Japan had been at war with the United
States
the first thing they wanted to know was
who had
won in 1997 in 1977 the Ministry of
Education reduced a section on World War
II within a standard history book of
several hundred pages to only six pages
which consisted mainly of pictures of
American fi firebombing of Tokyo a
picture of the ruins of Hiroshima and a
tally of Japan's War
dead the text neglected to mention the
casualties on on the other side Japanese
war atrocities or the forced evacuations
of Chinese and Korean prisoners to labor
camps in
Japan much of the censorship might have
gone unchallenged had it not been for
the efforts of one Brave Crusader in
1965 the Japanese historian Ana Saburo
sued the Japanese
government this lawsuit was the
beginning of a legal battle that would
span three decades and gain the backing
of thousands of sympathetic Japanese
followers the ministry interfered with
Ana's attempts to document the Nan King
Massacre for school children for example
in his textbook manuscript enega
wrote he wrote this quote immediately
after the occupation of Nan King the
Japanese Army killed numerous Chinese
soldiers and citizens this incident
became known as the as the Nan King
Massacre now when when his book got
checked by the
examiner The Examiner commented quote
readers might interpret this description
as meaning meaning that the Japanese
Army unilaterally massacred Chinese
immediately after the occupation this
passage should be revised so that it is
not interpreted in such a
way and here's what the passage
eventually got Chang to while battling
the fierce resistance of the Chinese
armed forces the Japanese occupied Nan
King and killed numerous Chinese
soldiers and civilians this incident
came to be known as the Nan King
Massacre that a statement end quote that
a statement might have been satisfied
that statement might have satisfied
textbook censors as a compromise between
a nega's argument and the ministry's
position on the massacre unfortunately
the statement is simply not true because
it implies that the massacre occurred in
the heat of
battle continuing on the examiner
demanded that Ena delete his description
of the rape itself claiming that the
violation of women is something that has
happened on every Battlefield in every
era of human history this is not an
issue that needs to be taken up with
respect to the Japanese Army in
particular even the word aggression was
deemed taboo aggression the censors
wrote is a term that contains negative
ethical
connotations
and that spirit that you can see very
clearly that Spirit of denial it carried
on which is why when this book came out
this book the rape of Nan King when it
came out there were still Japanese
nationalists that were staunchly against
it but Iris Chang who researched
intently and wrote with
passion she gave it all right she was a
daughter of Chinese American immigrants
and her her parents by the way had
connections to Nan King and escaped
there and both her parents had made it
to America and become College
professors and Iris
was compelled to tell this
story but like I said in the beginning
she was so close to this story that it
took a toll of its
own and she was a writer obviously she
got her bachelor's degree in journalism
and eventually a master's in writing
from John's Hopkins
University
and there's actually a
book that's written about Iris and the
book is written by iris's mother whose
name is Dr Ying Ying Chang and the book
is called the woman who could not
forget and I'm going to bring you
through some portions of this book so
this book again this is about Iris
Chang and it's written by her
mother this is how she
got this is how she decided she was
going to write about
this here we go quote although Iris
talked to us about her many book ideas
for her next book while she was writing
her first book her decision to write the
rape of Nan King came all of a sudden in
December
1994 as Iris told us and as described in
the book she made up her mind to write
about this most atrocious chapter of
history when she was attending a
conference in California on December
13th
1994 at the conference there was a photo
exhibition of the
war of the war crimes committed in China
in the 1930s taken when the the Japanese
Army invaded Chinese territory Iris
wrote in her book though I had heard so
much about the Nan King Massacre as a
child nothing prepared me for these
pictures Stark black and white images of
decapitated heads bellies ripped open
and nude women forced by their rapists
into various pornographic poses their
faces contorted into Unforgettable
expressions of Agony and
shame and she continued in a single
blinding moment I recognized the
fragility of not just life but The Human
Experience
itself later she told us in a telephone
update that she simply must write about
the rape of Nan King for her next book
it was a moral obligation and it would
be Justice for the victims as
well in 1998 after the rape of Nan King
had been published one Japanese reporter
interviewed Iris and asked her why did
you decide to write this book Iris
replied when I was a little girl my
parents shocked me with the story of the
rape of n King they told me that the
Japanese Imperial Army massacred
thousands of civilians in the capital of
China and butchered even small
children this left a powerful impression
on me and I went to local libraries to
learn more details but I couldn't find a
shred of information on the subject
there was nothing in my local school
libraries or public City libraries or in
my world history
textbooks still worse my teachers were
completely ignorant of this event
the event remained a question mark in my
mind for years until I saw an exhibit of
photographs on the subject in
1994 the horror of those photographs
inspired me to write the
book so that's how
Iris got involved in writing the book
and as a writer luckily she was also a
prolific letter writer and I'm going to
quote a bunch of her letters because her
mother saved a bunch of her letters and
and here is one that kind of describes I
think it's a good insight into what her
personality was like when she was
actually writing the book this was a
letter to her mom about what she was
doing on a day-to-day basis as she's
writing this book and this was her
second book she so she had already
written one book it had done okay but
this one was her you know her current
project and here's what she said about
it quote on a typical day I would rise
between 7:00 and 8:00 a.m. and take the
bus to Silver Spring Metro Station
fortunately there was a bus stop
directly across from Lee's house the
trip to the National Archives took about
45 minutes on public transportation and
the building was open by 8:45 a.m. I
spent my Mornings in the military
reference branch of the archives on the
13th floor looking through finding AIDS
and filling out cards to request boxes
from different collections of papers
dozens of boxes would be pulled from the
shelves placed on carts and made
available to me in the second floor
reading room which stayed open until
9:00 p.m. on Tuesday Thursdays and
Fridays I was usually there in the
afternoons and evenings scanning
documents tagging the ones that
pertained to the Nan King Massacre and
xeroxing them as quickly as
possible so she's digging deep into this
book doing massive amount of research
and you know research back then
was infinitely harder than it is now cuz
we have the
internet now as she began she assembled
all this information and she was star to
starting to speak about it starting to
write some articles about it before the
book came out and she was interviewed by
the San Jose Mercury News which was a
big newspaper up in the South Bay Area
of you know South Bay San Francisco and
uh she when she got done with that
interview she started getting a little
bit of
recognition so here's a letter to her
mom dear Mom here's the latest exciting
news I shall be the Master of Ceremonies
for what I believe will be the biggest
rape of Nan King conference ever the
event will take place at Stanford
University during the first weekend of
December hundreds of people from more
than 50 activist organizations all over
the globe will be there as well as
representatives from all major news
media organizations of California China
and Japan the goal of the three-day
Affair is to discuss legal strategy how
can we see seek reparations for the
victims through international law and un
resolutions how can we gather evidence
of atrocity for of atrocities for
lawsuits what methods should we use to
force the Japanese to accept
responsibility for its past
[Music]
misdeeds so she's in the game she's
getting after it she's starting to get
some leadership positions in here
and starting to get some
recognition now as she's continuing to
work here's another letter to her mom
dear Mom thank you for your
inspirational email I've been working on
my book all week and feel more confident
about my material the sections of the
book are so short that I organize each
chapter as I would a speech thinking of
the chapters as speeches forces me to
distill each idea into a tiny hard
gem lately I've been reading so many of
the world's classic speeches for
inspiration they are breathtaking in
their power and so much more pungent
than Pros in the evenings when I read
the speeches of Napoleon or Clarence
or Winston Churchill I feel engaged in
actual conversation with
them words are the only way to preserve
the essence of a
soul what excites me about speeches is
that even after the speakers are dead
and buried their Spirit lives
on to me this is true religion the best
form of life after
death this is the first time I have ever
devoted much attention to speeches my
previous Reading had only consisted
mainly of essays plays novels and
poetry love Iris so it's pretty cool
that you first of all I I I love that
letter because she's recognizing the
power of speech and she's she's
realizing that what she's doing as an
author is that's that's her that's her
Mark that she's going to leave on the
world and it's very interesting that
Ying Ying Chang is also an academic
she's you know obviously a really smart
person they're able to have these sort
of intellectual conversations in in
letters and they're all a really good
insight into what iris's mind what was
going through iris's mind as she did
this now the book comes out
there's it doesn't like jump out of the
gates but as it comes out there's a
little bit of controversy about it and
it's there's starting to be some
articles about it and some interviews
and she's getting some interviews and
the book starts to get some good
traction
back to the book on January 14th she
flew to Washington for a TV interview
with
PBS at the San Francisco airport she
left a telephone message for us and said
that she'd gotten a call from her
publisher and that her book was number
15 on the New York Times bestsellers
list her voice told us she was weeping
I'm sure they were tears of joy shiao
Jin which is the the dad and I were
jubilant we could not contain our
excitement for many days in the next
phone call we said Iris you've made it
so book hits the New York Times
bestseller that's a game changer for
Iris back to the book on on January 28th
Iris called us with excitement and said
that Laurel cook her publicist and Jack
mckuin of the CEO had called her in the
afternoon to tell her that her book was
up to number 11 on the New York Times
list her highest spot yet only two weeks
after first making the list when they
called she could hear wild cheering
whistling and clapping in the background
she was
overjoyed so it's like the big the big
thing in as as a writer is to make the
New York Times list and and and her
parents understand that too because
they're academics and you know they're
they're super stoked for
Iris now with the
success starts to come some stress and
that starts to reveal itself here's
another letter that she wrote dear Mom
I'm sorry that I sounded so rushed when
you called me at miran's home sometimes
I wonder if I've offended a lot of old
friends in the last few months by not
returning emails phone calls and letters
perhaps many people believe I've been
corrupted
already it's true that I've neglected my
loved ones for the last few months I
feel ashamed that I haven't yet brought
bought you a Mother's Day gift or even
even a card only this note that I'm
hastily writing from my laptop computer
perched up on a bed in Diana zeran's
house how I wish you could have been
there during the woman of the year
ceremony I told you I told the audience
how you inspired me over the years how
you served as my first role model so you
got another big award woman of the year
right please forgive me I love you
dearly even though I haven't found the
time to talk to you in the last few
weeks and in a few weeks will all be
reunited and the book tour will finally
be over I feel like a soldier returning
from a six-month War love
Iris so she's a person that feels guilt
you know and and the idea that she
hasn't been returning emails and phone
calls and she feels bad about it and
then I found this interesting perhaps
many people believe I've been corrupted
already oh so you made it big time and
now you're blowing me off so she's
feeling that pressure
too
back to the book when iris's book became
an international bestseller she reached
the status most writers can only dream
of she became a
celebrity but she also paid a price for
it in February 1998 after a long book
tour she had already told us that once
she came home she did not want to go out
anymore all she wanted to do was stay
home with Brett that was her husband
she'd been married now and have a good
sleep after after several weeks of
continuous book signings public speeches
and traveling she said her life was a
Non-Stop blur of airport lecture hall
Hotel Airport lecture hall Hotel the
responses to her speeches were
overwhelming wherever she went people
besieged her after every speech when she
came home she inevitably came down with
a cold or a flu only to recover in time
for the next book tour she was
physically
exhausted not only that
but during the book signings many old
Asian people came up to her Chinese
Korean Filipino Singaporean Indian they
poured out their personal stories of
suffering during World War II in in Asia
to her some of them wept and thanked her
for profusely for writing such a book
they said it's so frustrating to see
that Japan to this day hasn't formally
acknowledged their war crimes they
exclaimed it's about time Iris said that
on the one hand she felt rewarded that
she was sought out and greatly respected
by many people but on the other hand she
was mentally and emotionally drained
after hearing those stories on June 29th
1998 Iris wrote dear Mom I arrived
safely in New York today after giving a
well-received speech in Baltimore to the
women
doctors
actually it was very depressing during
the Q&A a Pakistani doctor told the
audience about the atrocities against B
Bali women in
1971 a Filipino doctor described how she
escaped the rape of Manila when she was
12 and an Indian doctor had discussed
the Indian tradition of suti which is
the burning of widows
alive others talked about the
internation International sex slave
industry the trafficking of women and
children female genital mutilation in
Africa you get the
idea it seemed there were endless
gruesome stories that people were eager
to share with
her on top of her busy schedule of book
tours outside people might not realize
that besides her traveling signings and
books and speeches she was constantly
bombarded with additional email requests
from news reporters for written
interviews sometimes there were 10 or 15
written questions for her to answers so
the reporters could write a news article
or
profile Iris to still could find time to
answer answer those questions
accordingly so she's just a she's just a
go-getter right she's not stopping
regardless of what's happening and now
as this book is gained all this
popularity now she's starting to get
some attacks as well from like I said
from the Japanese nationalists that are
saying oh this didn't happen you're
you're glorifying it or you're making it
sound like worse than it
was and here's the letter that she wrote
dear Mom tonight I read an article about
John St Steinbeck's life in the in the
Los Gatos Mountain area and learn that
the reception of The Grapes of Wrath
mirrored that of the rape of Nan King in
a letter to a friend Steinbeck wrote the
vilification of me out here from the
large land owners and bankers is pretty
bad the latest rumor started by them
that the ois hate me for lying about
them so I'm frightened at the rolling
might of this thing it is completely out
of hand I mean the kind of Hysteria
about the book is growing that is not
healthy love Iris so she feels the same
way that she's starting to this book is
almost
becoming more powerful than she you know
more than she can
control and here's another another
letter that she
wrote a few nights ago I leafed through
Richard rh's autobiography A whole in
the world after our lunch together as
you know rhs was starved beat
and
psychologically abused as a child by his
stepmother his mother had committed
suicide by shooting herself and his
father degenerated into an alcoholic
leaving him virtually incapable of
protecting his family every time I
reread this book I'm convinced that
Richard rhods is lucky to be alive he
was a genuine victim but even his
experience pales in comparison to the
stories of abandoned children in the PRC
orphanages that's People's Republic of
China I don't even want to get into that
right
now delving into history into other
people's stories places all our problems
into
perspective time and again we have to
remind ourselves how extraordinarily
lucky we are much love
Iris and clearly that's something that I
talk about on a regular basis you look
at the suffering that other people go
through and it reminds you of how lucky
we are not to be in those
situations but it seemed like Iris was
having a hard time maintaining
that positive outlook and she keeps
getting dragged down into the
darkness back to the book hearing that
peanuts cartoonist Charles Schultz had
died Iris was quite sentimental and
wrote me a letter and here's the letter
quote dear Mom I have a favorite ask you
can you save the last Peanuts comic
strip that appeared yesterday and mail
it to me I'm still reeling from the news
of Charles Schultz's death it's the end
of an
era I still remember all the hours I
spent reading peanuts books as a child
do you recall the time we went together
to a garage sale in champagne and you
brought me my first Snoopy cartoon book
a used paperback already yellow with age
that's when I first fell in love with
the Peanuts comic strip you and Dad grew
up with the PE Peanuts cartoon as well
in Chinese new newspapers in Taiwan
making both of you part of the peanuts
era as well years later in Santa Barbara
I met Charles solch in person at the SB
writers Conference during his lecture
however I was surprised by his demeanor
which was bitter gloomy and depressed
almost
nasty after his lecture I stood in a
long line waiting for Schultz to
autograph a copy of his book when I
finally stood in front of him I asked
Schultz if if I could write a profile
about him for the New Yorker or some
other major mag
magazine why is a young person like you
interested in an old man like me was his
response at the time I thought he was
being sarcastic but later I learned that
Schultz like Charlie Brown is a terribly
insecure person fundamentally convinced
of his own
unworthiness that was the last time I
ever spoke I ever saw Schultz but last
year I had one more opportunity to see
him to make a long story short I didn't
have time to make the long 2-hour drive
to Santa Rose and I figured I would see
Schultz at the next Santa barbar's
writers conference I never expected that
Schultz would pass away only a few
months
later do you think Charles Schultz
committed suicide don't you find it odd
that he died the night before his final
strip ran in the Sunday newspaper as you
know peanuts ran from 1950 to 2000 a
perfect 50 years and he died right when
the strip ended but life is seldom as
neat and tidy as a cartoon box it's
almost as if he timed his dramatic exit
from this world achieving his final
deadline love
Iris continuing on it seems like Iris
could not get the death of Charles SCH
Schultz off her mind the next day she
wrote to me again about him dear Mom I
think it was Charles Schultz's pessimism
as well as his ability to understand
human failure insecurity heartbreak that
made Millions love peanuts you're
absolutely right Schultz had no reason
whatsoever to be depressed after
achieving wealth and fame at such an
early
age but depression is not
rational perhaps he did have a mental
problem or some chemically induced
condition but whatever it was it
prevented him from losing touch with The
Underdogs of the
world it's strange but I still feel a
void in my heart after Schultz's death
even though I never knew him and didn't
particularly like him after our meeting
in person it made me wonder what is the
secret to Schultz's magic
appeal the answer I believe is simple
Schultz understands a heart of a loser
he captur those moments in life when we
feel utterly unloved unloved unwanted
and
alone all of us no matter how successful
have felt like losers at some point in
life
love
Iris you're starting to see there's a
there's
a an indication right there's an
indication she's sort of seeing things
like depression in other people
regardless of you know how successful
they are and at this point you know
she's a New York Times bestseller Woman
of the Year all this other stuff so
she's successful and yet she's
recognizing how that doesn't really mean
anything and you can still
be
depressed after September 11th
2001 she wrote this a few days after it
she wrote
this again to her mom and dad in this
case quote events are unfolding faster
than I can react to them first the WTC
and Pentagon tragedies then the Japanese
prime ministers unexpected apology to
the Comfort women and now a major Court
victory of a former Korean slave laborer
against a Japanese
corporation this week I tried to work on
my book and recover from General
exhaustion and a mild case of the flu
but I have to admit it's hard to stay
focused I plan to do nothing more than
write exercise and rest for the next few
weeks love
Iris so she's now working on her next
book still working hard probably working
too hard not focusing enough and her mom
now she's got a kid as well and we know
that adding a kid into the mix doesn't
make things you know doesn't give you
more free time we can promise you that
nope and she's married now she has a a
son
and her mom actually started like
putting some pressure on her and said
hey you know you got a kid now you got
to spend you know maybe you're going a
little
overboard with the
work back to the book on October 3rd
2003 in an email I asked Iris whether
she was putting too much emphasis on her
career placing her career before for her
family she replied that is not true it's
just that I believe that I have some
power to shape my destiny and I want
Christopher to that's the son I want
Christopher to have his mother a strong
to have in his mother a strong Role
Model A person who is his own individual
impervious to the whims of others I
cannot teach Christopher to be an
intellectual and a socially responsible
person unless I demonstrate to him
through my actions that I myself am such
a person I want to teach Christopher
that it is far better to
belong to the critical minority than the
unquestioning majority I want to teach
him the ability to think independently
to evaluate ideas and information on his
own without the official sanction of the
authorities and if possible to
create these qualities are not
universally popular in our society my
tendency to stand alone apart from the
crowd has caused me a great pain and
suffering throughout my life but in the
end I am stronger and better person
because of
it
now she's continuing on she's continuing
to just kind of grind and grind and
grind and there's an
incident she's gone on a trip to
Louisville Kentucky
and things start going sideways back to
the book that night we went to sleep and
assumed that Iris would be all right but
about 2: a.m. California time in the
early morning of Friday August 13th we
were awakened by a phone call I picked
up the phone and it was Iris her voice
was shaking and she told me she hadd
seen some frightening pictures on the TV
in her hotel room Iris and I then had a
conversation about this apparently she
could not fall asleep so she turned on
the TV I asked her what kind of pictures
were on the TV screen she said it showed
some horrible atrocities and ugly images
of children torn apart by Wars she said
that the TV was showing something
similar to scenes from hell like an
unimagined World War
II she had turned off their TV waited a
while and then turned it on again to
find the ugly images had
disappeared I responded that maybe the
TV had been showing a war movie It's
very possible I said that during the we
hours of the night TV stations would
show such a genre of horror films
then Iris told me she did not feel
things had been quite right from the
very moment she'd arrived at the hotel
the clerk at the front desk looked
suspicious to her and spoke to a person
who later kept looking at the window of
her room while Iris was still talking
with me on the phone she told me that
she could still see that person standing
outside on the lawn in Fr not far from
her room he looked at her window and as
she peered through her curtain she told
me she suspected her room was wired and
that what she had seen on TV was real
and intentionally shown to threaten her
so she's getting paranoid she's paranoid
that Japanese nationalists are coming
after her she's and it's starting to
affect her mind back to the book it was
past 5:00 a.m. in Kentucky I asked her
had she gotten any sleep at all she said
she couldn't fall asleep and she was
exhausted and had a terrible headache
she was sick I could tell she had to be
ill because she had not been able to
sleep for 3 or 4 days prior to the trip
she also had not eaten nor had she drunk
any liquid for some time she said she
had ordered some takeout dinner that was
delivered to her room but she did not
have any appetite and hadn't eaten
anything she didn't want to drink
anything either afraid that someone
might poison
her I knew that under severe sleep
deprivation people could have
delusions
so her parents decide they're going to
they're going to fly well she has a
breakdown and they get a call saying hey
something happened to Iris you need to
get out here they fly out to
Louisville as soon as they get to
Louisville they go to the hospital when
she gets when they get to the hospital
she they they go to find her and she's
in the psychiatric
unit and they she was sent to the
psychiatric unit because they hadn't
found anything wrong with her physically
which you know would include in my
opinion that includes like she's not
dehydrated she's not starving she's got
some psychiatric issues
so back to the book in the evening the
doctor finally came in and met with us
he briefed us on iris's condition in
front of all of us he believed Iris had
experienced a so-called brief reactive
psychosis due to stress conditions such
as lack of sleep and
food he added that her condition could
also be a possible onset of bipolar
disorder and recommended that Iris see a
doctor for followup after her return
home he gave us a reference he also
prescribed an anticho D drug RAR draw
RAR doll 2 milligrams a day for Iris to
take for at least a
year
and then they they get in the cab and as
she get in the cab she's kind of like
making statements and saying strange
things about what she sees billboard
she's making strange comments about them
and finally they land at San Jose
airport and it go back to the book we
called Michael and that's that's uh the
son or iris's brother we called Michael
to come pick us up while we were waiting
for Michael Iris said that she felt
dizzy and had a headache she told me
that things seemed distorted to her and
that the expressions of people around
her were strange at that time we did not
know how powerful psychiatric drugs were
and thought that iris's behavior was
strange I later realized that while in
the hospital Iris had been given heavy
doses of RIS doll and a tranquilizer to
calm her down the side effect of
psychiatric drugs could be severe that
explained why she felt dizzy and had a
headache and Distortion of her visual
perception so she's now on these drugs
she's she's taking the the the risper
draw uh 2 milligrams a day the
medicine's making her super sleepy and
once they're back in the Bay Area the
Mom yingying starts looking for a you
know a board certifi iied psychiatrist
to bring her to and she ends up with
this guy that they call Dr
B back to the book Iris was now seeing
Dr B once a week and she persuaded him
to reduce her dosage dosage of risol
risol by half from 1 milligram or from 2
1 milligram from from two down to one
from the very beginning Iris did not
like to take any drugs and she kept
trying to reduce the dosage or stop it
entirely the rest of the family was
hoping that with the risper doll Iris
would be less depressed but to no avail
there was no difference so interestingly
iris is saying hey I don't want to take
this drug you know I want to get off of
it and they're all saying look just keep
taking it
and eventually he just he prescribes her
with another drug which is called
amplify and as soon as back to the book
as soon as Iris took the amplify 10
milligrams she became excessively sleepy
she could sleep for 12 hours or more
straight so now she's sleeping I mean 12
hours a
day bad and back to the book Iris felt
that her illness and inability to take
care of Christopher was a burden to
everyone something she hated I could see
that she was very sad and felt
helpless so this continues on and
finally uh they go back to a meeting
with Dr B Dr B stunned us all with what
he said next in a very serious tone he
said he thought Iris condition was very
grave and he suggested that Iris check
into a recovery facility he said that
the facility was in Salo near the beach
it was quite ideal for mental patients
to recuperate as soon as Iris heard this
she immediately showed her disapproval I
could understand her suspicion of any
facility designed for so-called mental
patients she had learned many historical
instances of government persecution of
political dissidents one way was to put
those dissidents into mental
institutions and abuse them sometimes
leading to death I did not blame her for
her suspicions she was already
suspecting that evil forces were at work
against her for what she had written and
done in the name of
Justice Dr B she told Dr B that she did
not think her mental state was that bad
and that she didn't need to go to
recovery
facility so they start looking
for someone else to take her to besides
Dr
B and now she gets prescribed another
drug which is called
Celexa and so she's on Alexa and she's
on AB
ABI and back to the book at this time or
sorry Abilify at this time Iris was
already experiencing the strong side
effects of Abilify most obvious were her
lack of energy and the fact that she was
drowsy all the time in addition when she
woke up from her daily nap she
complained that her shoulders and leg
joints were sore which were new symptoms
that she thought likely to have been
caused by the drug I was worried about
the side effects of Abilify and vo my
concern to Dr B he said the dosage was
the lowest possible and that the side
effects would gradually disappear in
retrospect it appears to us that Abilify
had a big impact on iris's mental state
it was a turning point in her condition
became worse after she started taking
ambify and L and then later worsened
even more with Celexa
so now a another incident takes place
she kind of disappears for a little bit
no one really knows where she is they
call the cops to find out
eventually she calls back and she says
hey look I was out I was tired I checked
into a hotel to uh get some sleep that's
the story she tells and she's her mom
says she sounds guilty as she's trying
to tell this story story and then a few
days later they they find the some
sleeping pills and a bottle of vodka and
they kind of realized that
she was you know thinking about
committing suicide but you know her mom
says she probably just went into a room
to do that and fell asleep when she woke
up I guess she changed her mind
and you know back to the book here on
the drugs that she was taking we now
know that a bifi website warns that the
drug can affect your judgment thinking
or motor skills as well as the side
effects of increasing risk of suicide
drowsiness anxiety and muscle stiffness
and the Celexa website warns about
suicide
anxiety and self-destructive or
aggressive impulses so these drugs that
you take for these problems have side
effects that sound you know worse worse
than the problem than what the problem
is and she goes on to say that that the
first attempt at suicide that she made
so this this attempt was when she was
when she was on 10 milligrams of
Abilify and the other thing that that
mentions in these about these drugs is
that when you change prescription when
you change doses or you go on or off of
them that's when the you're most
vulnerable and so that that suicide
attempt was in line with one of those
changes
so they go back to now they're with
another doctor doc who they call Doctor
C going back to the book Iris stopped
taking select on October 7th after the
support group meeting she told Dr C on
the phone that she would discontinue
seeing him if he insisted on her taking
the med medicine as a compromise Dr C
persuaded her to continue seeing him and
then he would decide whether she could
gradually decrease the dosage of risper
doll which she was still on all all of
us told Iris that both the medication
and the Psychotherapy sessions were
needed for rapid recovery if she didn't
want to take the medication then at
least she should have she should have
Psychotherapy sessions with the doctor
she agreed to continue seeing Dr C
looking back at what ended up happening
it was so ironic Iris was the one who
did not want to take the medication
whereas the rest of the family believed
in doctors and thought the medication
would help
her
continuing on the morning of Thursday
October 21st when I went to see her she
was very unhappy and complained that I
was following her too
closely I found she had not eaten well
the night before so I
suggested going out for lunch we drove
to a nearby restaurant in the parking
lot when she stopped the car she sat
there and told me without any expression
that she wanted to cry but had no
tears her face was greenish and in a
horrible depressed state at this time
she had already mentioned that she did
not want to live
anymore I also noticed that her arm and
leg movements and facial expressions
were
rigid and it seemed even worse that she
wanted to cry but had no
tears back then I did not suspect that
all these
symptoms could be the serious side
effects of the
medications
Iris began to feel hopeless I later
realized she wanted to carry out her
plan and she did not want us to find out
in the last week of her life she
prohibited me from visiting her she did
not even want me to call her and did not
return my calls or my
emails in that final week Shia Jinn and
I took a walk ourselves to ease our
worries I went to Apollo Alta support
group on Wednesday November 3rd Shia Jin
and I went to another support group in
San Jose on Friday November
5th we tried to gather information on
how to deal with depression and loved
ones who were possibly
suicidal for all this time she was
actively planning her Final Exit while
we tried to find a way to rescue her
we raced against her and we did not
realize that she would carry out her
plan so
quickly one week later on November
9th she was
gone and here is the
note that was
[Music]
found next to iris's computer
dear Brett mom dad and
Mike for the last few weeks I have been
struggling with my decision as to
whether I should live or
die as I mentioned to Brett when you
believe you have a future you think of
terms of generations and
years when you do not you live just by
the day you live not just by the
day but by the
minute you don't want someone who will
live out the rest of her days as a mere
shell of her former
self I had considered running away but I
will never be able to escape from myself
and my
thoughts I am doing this because I am
too weak to withstand the years of pain
and Agony
ahead each breath is becoming difficult
for me to
take the anxiety can be compared to
drowning in an open
sea I know that my actions will transfer
some of this pain to others indeed those
who love me the
most please forgive
me forgive me because I cannot forgive
myself
love
Iris and iris's Mom closes out the book
saying it was an untimely
death over the years Iris had always
commented that life was too short for
her to finish the thing she wanted to
accomplish she said many times that she
wanted to write more books to make films
and record more oral
histories it was so painful to realize
that many of her dreams were not
fulfilled yet it is not how she died but
rather how she live that will be her
Legacy whenever I think of Iris the
memories of loving daughter and a
beautiful soul will always remain with
me in her short 36 years she had
inspired many many people in the world
with her Noble Spirit her passion
dedication sincerity and
determination in preserving historical
truth in pursuing Justice for the
voiceless
victims Iris was a woman whose heart
beat passionately for those who
suffered she was a woman who could not
forget she could not forget their Agony
and she refused to let their stories go
Untold iris's life was short but
brilliant like a splendid rainbow across
the sky one that the goddess she was
named after would be proud
of iris's rainbow was
magnificent Vanishing
quickly a rainbow Vanishing
quickly
and I guess that that is what we all
are a rainbow Vanishing
quickly
but before we
vanish I
say
shine
shine all that darkness in the
world be the
light be the color be the good and the
strong and the brightness that drives
away the
dark
we have but one chance
here one chance one opportunity to
stretch across the sky and
shine value
that
value that value
life and
know that the light will
spread and
good will
prevail it will prevail over evil so
long as we stand
up stand
up against all that wickedness in the
world
we stand
up and
shine and I think
that's all I've got for
tonight
Echo yes want you go ahead and take the
mic for a minute there
sure while I decompress over on this
side
sure I was
uh I was talking with Greg train
yesterday and you can
complain about something where you can
embra this is one of the big things I
kind of learned from you and this is
like when you look at your own situation
compared to other you know past
situations that are way worse right so
one you you start with okay your your
situation isn't that bad
that's what you start with then you go
on to okay my situation these are small
teeny tiny CH challenges that all you
have to do is approach them
in this way of like embracing it you
know how like um like anytime okay
anytime you're feeling frustrated about
your situation or whatever right and
really in P when you put it in
perspective these are small challenges
that you just got to overcome you take
it on as it's like yeah you want to put
more work on my play at I it cuz I can
handle it and I'll do it the best and
watch me work you know that is good and
interesting you
know when T when we had Tim Ferris on
here and when I did Tim Ferris interview
the first time I was on his podcast and
he it's the thing that I talked about
when he came on here like I he asked the
question sort of saying hey how close do
you get to the darkness before it
consumes you and I've talked about
before uh you know if you stare in into
the soul of a monster you have to be
careful because you might become a
Monster yeah and so I I mean I I think
yeah there's the drugs that she got put
on obviously played a role but she got
in this world where all she saw was the
bad yeah and I think that to Tim Ferris
is point where he was saying to me like
hey how often should I get close to the
darkness you know how often should I
look at that and you know my response
was hey you in order to know the light
you you got to know the
darkness but you can absolutely go too
far in that direction yeah and you can
say to yourself wow the world is evil
and everyone's evil and underneath the
surface everyone could turn into this
Imperial Japanese soldier and commit
these atrocities and that is what you
[Music]
absolutely and I I would say be careful
I don't know if that's the right word I
guess it is the right word be careful
but to me what you have to do is you you
have to balance it and to me as an
American as a man there's so much good
right I think that people generally get
get jaded to all the good that's out
there and that's why I say hey you know
what look over here at the darkness but
for someone that's stuck in a horrible
place in a horrible situation in life
that's those those folks got to look out
and say wait a second there's not
there's so much good out there you know
if you take a like that's clearly I mean
you look at look at Iris changen I mean
she is smart and successful and
beautiful and well-liked and had a she
came up with an amazing family her
parents were adored her right she had
every thing in her life was good right
and she lost all that she you know what
it's like a if you talk to anybody that
flies planes right MH if you go into a
cloud you lose your orientation it
happens in diving too it happens when
you're surfing if you if you fall off a
big wave and you're getting rolled
around sometimes it can be hard to tell
which way is up right it can happen you
know guys drive drive their airplanes
they get lost in a cloud they drive
their airplanes into a mountain or they
drive it into the ground because they
don't they get disoriented and they lose
sight of which way is up and or you're
underwater and you lose sight of which
way is up that's what you have to watch
out for you got to be able to say wait a
second if everything is black around me
okay stop yeah let me get oriented let
me f let me check my control panel in
the water it's it's really easy you got
to look for bubbles which way are the
where are the bubbles the bubbles are
going to go up mhm and so when you get
trapped in that Darkness these people
end up in these situations where
everything looks black stop mhm you're
disoriented you you just can't see you
don't know the right direction it's okay
figure out where the bubbles are they're
going to go to the surface and when they
get to the surface there's going to be
light and you're going to be okay but
obviously Iris she got draag dragged
down and dis disoriented in the darkness
and she couldn't figure out that she had
a husband and a son and a family and
money and she had all these beautiful
things in her life yeah which a lot of
times especially if you go full speed in
that direction where you don't know
which way is up so you're going down
even the good things that come in you
know like even you know when you get
paranoid something good and you're like
that's bad for instance for instance
she's on a trip in Lou Louisville going
to go do a speech or whatever and some's
checking her in the hotel maybe someone
was saying oh I think that's Iris Chang
I saw on TV instead she's thinking oh
it's some nationalists that are coming
to get me so yeah she was absolutely so
that's something that that I think and
it's something that for for those of us
that are not in that situation how do
you pay attention and observe people and
make sure that your friends or people
you know or people that are in bad
situations how do you make sure that
they're getting enough that they know
how to orient themselves and get back to
the surface and get away from all that
horribleness when you approach thing and
I was talking to Greg that's kind of
what it and this just reminded me of it
when you approach things like that you
you know how like you said you're going
down if you don't know which way is up
you're going down a good thing you're
going to look at that's a bad thing
reinforcing my whole Direction by the
way so if you approach it in a way where
things that even would be frustrating to
like an everyday person if you approach
it like good um you know I'm the one to
do this thing bring the challenge cuz
the challenges are good you know if
that's the approach
that'll reinforce that way of thinking
yes so you will be going you know that
and really when you explore
Darkness that's not to embrace the
darkness and be dark like how you said
don't become the de that's basically
you're trying to avoid ignorance that's
what you're doing because you got no
dark a contrast it's a contrast so you
can see okay guess what this and and for
this case I mean obviously I I pray I
never have to read anything as heinous
as that again ever on this show yeah me
too thank
but that happened right that happened
that happened we should not you
shouldn't go through life and not
realize that that happened yeah that
that happened to that human beings did
that to other human beings as horrible
as it is you need to realize that that
is a part of our human history so that
way you can say you could you recognize
and say okay this is this can happen and
we need to watch out for it and
yeah
so yeah look out for your friends keep
them knowing that there's keep them
knowing which direction they're heading
in and when you see someone going
sideways bring them grab them especially
with the I mean this is kind of a it's
specific to this story but the uh the
drugs you know when you take Medicaid
cuz that's a big one man it can mess up
your even like how you said when you get
off the drugs you know cuz this these
are all chemical things in your brain
made for certain things so when that
part goes sideways you can't like reason
necessarily with someone you know they
can't reason with you can't reason with
yourself you know stuff that would seem
obvious hey if I you know walk off this
Cliff it's obvious that's bad it doesn't
really work that way if like your
chemicals are off you know totally so
yeah you kind of got to you know like
look out for somebody if you can see
that happening yeah no doubt and it's
very it's very interesting the the the
mind is so incredibly
durable but at the same time it's just
totally fragile and little some little
change to the to the composition or to
the to the chemicals that are in or to
the thought patterns that are in it you
know can be really drastic changes on a
on a
person yeah you ever you ever have a
real bad flu and a fever and then you're
trying to go to
sleep and then yes I have you know and
it's almost like a mix between dreaming
hallucinating and like you cuz man it's
like your thoughts are all jumbled up
you okay you want you want me to tell
you an echo story right now yes this
will be a stupid Echo story soce
yourself awesome so I was like 20 I was
23 years old or something and I was
doing the dishes speaking of doing the
dishes I was doing the dishes and I
turned on the water and I didn't see
what was happening but this
little stream a tiny little stream of
water had had broken through the pipe at
some point in the handle and it and it
started to land on my hand well I didn't
know that it was water cuz it it must
have been like the similar temperature
to what my body was at the time and so I
see this and it looks for for a quarter
of a second it looks like my hand is
blistering it's just and it's spreading
so rapidly and for a quarter of a second
I thought to myself I'm being attacked
by chemical warfare and I'm going to die
in the next next half a second I'm dead
I think we were we were doing some
chemical warfare training or whatever
and so at that moment for about a half a
second I thought I'm about to die and it
only lasted about then I realized it was
water and I said ohol let finish the
dises but my point is that mentally yeah
what if you know a different situation I
could get locked into that mode and when
you see Iris going hey these people are
coming after me if you get mentally
locked in that mode and you start seeing
things that are that that you you start
imposing or overlaying your reality over
actual reality you start augmenting
reality yourself that gets really really
scary yeah like when you think someone's
mad at you you read that you think
someone's mad at you so you're looking
for all the little cues you know dang is
this person mad at me or or are they not
and normal everyday stuff you know why
didn't why didn't she text me back
quickly it took her 5 minutes I know
usually she she puts a smiley face no
smiley face this time you know she hates
you yeah she's mad I know she's mad
something's wrong but yeah so yeah if
you have meanwhile they're like I don't
know what the hell you talking about you
know it's interesting anyway speaking of
uh being mad or should I say the
opposite of being mad so this is what
you do take Alpha Brain Alpha
rainy the Pre-Workout performance and
strength
mhm and go workout see what happen that
will make you feel better report back
report back yeah um actually that's
something Iris and her mom both referred
to a couple times in here they were like
her mom would say you know I want to I
want you to go exercise with me and I
you know I should have put that in the
podcast but but hey get the book and
read it yourself I mean that's what you
need to do I should have said that
earlier the Rap andan King absolutely
you know get
it try and read it when you're in a
happy place right yeah it's it's a hard
hard read it's might be the hardest read
of any read possible I don't know what
could be harder than that and and then
the book the woman who could not forget
by Ying Ying Chang which again
Chronicles her life and it's a really
beautiful story and with with obviously
with a tragic ending and hopefully
lessons learned from it one of the
lessons being be physically be
physically active and her mom was trying
to get her to go to the gym with her and
work out with her because there's no
doubt it's it's it's it's
physiologically fact physiological fact
when you work out you get endorphins
released you feel better 100% yeah and
it also which is good I just heard this
oh no I was Joe
Rogan um doct Rhonda Patrick is her
name she was talking about how working
at exercise like is a is one of the more
powerful anti-aging things so you know
like when you get older um you know
people you know Alzheimer and all she
said not for physical aging but for
mental
aging that that's what yeah yeah so man
it's just a allaround good deal bro this
is so one time I think I even mention no
I didn't mention this so one time I I
might have drank maybe the night before
this was like maybe a few months ago and
I didn't work out for a while you know I
was like you know immersed in I don't
know work I don't know either way it
didn't work it was no no no got sick and
then I got hurt so I you know so you
cured that with the
bottle don't do that compounded compound
oh I'm going to make myself feel better
no you're not actually go it works yeah
I probably compound go continue your
story and tell everyone what not to do
don't do this no but there's a happy
ending so at the so boom I was over the
sickness my injury was good and I worked
and I worked out kind of hard too and it
was weird because I went in the workout
thinking okay I'm glad I get to go work
out but when when you're done okay I'll
admit this and I think a lot of people
have these thoughts
where maybe you've done something like
maybe your routine for whatever reason
is going over and over like just real
repetitive and then after a while yeah
true but I'm just saying sometimes these
thoughts of like what does all this even
mean like what what what okay I'm going
to get this and this and it's like you
think too much after a while and so at
the end of you know life it's like okay
I did all this
it just I don't know it just didn't
really I was having some of those
thoughts they weren't like super heavy
or nothing but they're in there they're
like okay great anyway so anyway fast
forward I worked out did the
workout got after it textbook definition
of God after it that was my workout I
was done in and actually not even done I
was like in the middle of the workout
and I was like dang life has straight up
meaning like this is what but life is
and not necessarily the work I'm just
saying everything I'm doing you know it
was that feeling was that the alphab
braid must have been must have been
alphab so what you're saying is get
alphab what I'm saying go work out well
I like that part too you got it I'm not
saying you got to but I'm saying if you
I'm say yeah work out work out for sure
change your life take on it big time
yeah so the Alpha Brain um that's a neut
Tropic that helps your memory and
whatnot so anyway if you're going to
work out and you want to take some
supplements which I recommend now I was
never supplement person I tried them mhm
but never was really into them or I'd be
like you got to take
this take the
Pre-Workout performance and strength
that's what it's called check take that
one what about shroom Tech I'd say take
the shroom Tech here's the thing with
I've been stacking them I'm telling you
see watch out I haven't been taking
shrimp tech oh really I feel like that's
like cheating not cheating cheating but
I mean in Jiu-Jitsu I mean I don't feel
like it's cheating no it's not cheating
but I feel like you just said you
thought it was cheating I feel like but
I'll tell you what it doesn't matter I
mean when it comes down to it shroom
Tech or no shroom Tech bring
it yeah all right nonetheless my
original point was okay working out
that's the enhancer that's the enhancer
if you want to enhance
to you keep you keep making me think of
more stuff okay I'll stop talking yeah
and then I feel like oh I should talk
about that anyway working out is
important part that enhances the life
yes Alpha Brain these supplements Alpha
Brain shroom Tech all these other ones
that enhances the workout which is the
enhancer so enhance the enhancer kind of
thing anyway if you like these things
you want 10% off you don't want to pay
full price or maybe do I don't know but
if you don't go on it.com joaco 10% off
support yourself as well and your
wallet I want to talk about Amazon
clickthrough
that's a good way to support that's good
because it's like you know small little
thing doesn't cost you anything as you
always say and um you know big result
big
support yeah I'm going to make the
sodium in the fish tank analogy I'm
going to do it really yeah good I wasn't
expecting that at all yeah you throw the
sodium in water and it blows up small
spece of sodium metal boom blows up
that's important that you said that but
what would be more important would be to
actually say how you do Amazon
clickthrough yeah so yeah I think you're
right about that so what you do is you
go to jock podcast.com little Banner on
the side there's the the the UK one.
co.uk as well is there Germany yes
there's Germany I think yeah I think I'm
pretty sure yeah it's right there on the
side boom the the the main one the top
one or the the one top is the the US One
amazon.com um click through there before
you do your Amazon shopping that's the
way to support doesn't cost you anything
small action big reaction be the sodium
be the
sodium Joo has a store it's called Joo
store URL Joost store.com if you want
shirts discipline equals
Freedom they're all Joo approved and
official go on there look at them if you
like them get a shirt get a shirt
they're not all Joo approved cuz I
didn't approve the pink women's t-shirt
yeah that's true that was not approved
right that was actually Joo unapproved
yeah but we there was Mutiny and
Rebellion yeah which is kind of part of
the game too right no not
really well according to the shirts that
we got it is yeah apparently so that one
is technically not Joo approved but it's
Joo unapproved so it's it's dope
nonetheless and um if you think they're
solid then yeah get a shirt man support
that way it's a good way to support yeah
there's some hoodies on there and some
rashu guards um I'm beginning to see
more and more people with the rashu
guards yeah the rashu guards seem to be
popular yeah at least a victory MMA and
fitness yeah no and online as well see
you guys doing it um anyway look at them
if you like something get something
that's a good way to support coming out
with a new travel
mug new and improved new and improved
high
quality higher quality higher quality
yes like
technically well you know hold you if
you put something hot in there hope
makes it keeps it hot for a long time
hours I for eight hours or something
like that it's cold same thing I think
cold keeps it long keep it cold longer
anyway that'll be on the store in two
weeks
yeah also good way to support and this
is actually supporting yourself big time
it's like a little helper it's like when
you're benching you ever bench bench PR
I don't bench much anymore okay so
in the event of you benching this is
what it's like if benching is the
analogy it's like someone spotting you
if you need it this is what it is
psychological
warfare you like it is right it's like a
spot you don't need it necessarily every
day you don't need it all the time maybe
you do maybe you don't depends on you
know a lot of things but if you do need
it even if you just want it hey can you
spot me I might get the I'll probably
get all eight but you're there you know
just in case that's what this is so if
you're like hey I'm going to okay this
is what is for those who don't know a
lot of people do know but if you don't
know it's an album you can buy from
iTunes with tracks on it for different
scenarios of what weakness you'd call it
moments of weakness moments of weakness
and you need a little spot you need a
little spot and guess who's spotting you
Joo that's the guy to spot right very
dependable very reliable punctual all
that stuff little twoin they're like two
minutes long give or take yeah there's
one about you know before you're going
to go and eat yeah there's a one called
sugarcoated lies yeah I think that one
might be a good
one you know at the end of that one
which is I think one of the more
memorable moments lines whatever when
you say something about mobilize your
will cuz your will is stronger than the
will of a donut right yeah factual BR
and that's the when you hear isn't it
pretty sad though you think youself okay
I'm not going to eat this donut I'm just
going to hold my Willow but then somehow
the the will cuz a war is is a war of
Wills right that's the war is so now if
you lose that war against the dut means
your will is weaker than a donut a donut
yeah that's not going to happen
noal Warfare play you put it into
perspective you're like here's the dut
and you're like your wheel is stronger
than the dut and then you eat the dut
you basically said I understand that s
that this Donut's will is stronger than
mine don't want to be that person and
that's your life right there man put
perspective anyway if you need that spot
psychological warfare from D willink do
a search iTunes and it's also on other
things that aren't iTunes yeah so Amazon
music it's on Google is it on Google
Play I'm pretty sure yeah anywhere where
you you can get like mp3 music yeah ex
do they call that anymore MP is that
still a Thing MP3 music well MP3 is just
the file type so but remember there used
to be MP3 players yeah are there still
yeah technically everything that can
play mp3s is an MP3 player you know so
yeah get uh check that one out that
one's a good and it's a good way to
support you know so that's it's the all
round circle of support in that way yeah
um also if you want to get some joa
white
tea you can get it you can get that on
Amazon and when you get it I know some
people are a little nervous when they
try it for the first time just be
careful you don't want to you know be in
a situation where where you you you're
going to go a little bit harder than
normal right so be ready for that when
you when you break out the jock you can
get once you've used it before you don't
have to worry about it there's no
precautionary once you're once you're
using it yeah but when you start yeah be
careful because you're going to go with
that little extra something you're going
to go on attack mode yeah it's kind of
like when you turn on your car and the
volume is up a little bit more than
you're ready for you're like oh but then
if you do it again you're like I you
same thing same thing so watch out for
that jao YT on Amazon also for
international orders it's on eBay the
official listing is of the Joo podcast
sold by pear resourcing so if you're
International and you want to get it you
can do that and for those of you that
are in in America that it says you see
that the shipping is $100 that's not for
you to get it from
there it's for you to get on Amazon if
you're in America if you're overseas the
shipping won't show on $100 it'll show
whatever the the cost is so if you're
I've had a couple people like say why is
the shipping $100 it's not it's Amazon
Prime the shipping is no cost don't get
it from eBay you understand what I'm
saying so if you're in the US if you're
in the US e go to eBay and try and get
it the shipping will show us $100 don't
get it from eBay you're not supposed to
we don't want to sell to everybody in
America we can't handle that but we can
sell to some people overseas here's what
you
do Joo
t.com and that has this information on
it too so it doesn't have that
particular information but it's a it's
like just a basic website um dang we did
I don't know why I didn't mention this
before it's a basic website it's like oh
you're in the US order from here you're
in the international order from here
jo.com joe.com it's on it's on Joo store
too but it's like you got to go to the
tab and then go to the page you know
it's it it's it's a thing but go to
joe.com if you if you're just down for
the tea boom just need the tea there you
go all right well that's well thank you
for informing us of that yet another
website for those of you that are asking
to get after it
mugs we're looking at march to be honest
with you this
so keep looking um
also you know uh kids we got kids out
there running around we know we know
that kids are impressionable yes right
as they're growing up we know that we
also know that it's hard to be a kid
right you come up against hard times and
if you want to help kids get through
some hard times
you can order this book that I just
wrote pre-order it it's called way the
warrior kid and this is the weird thing
about this book um so the other day I
was talking to somebody it might have
even been you I was talking after I got
done with edits like the final edits I
was talking to someone yeah you know I
just finished the final edits and I said
and it's
awesome and then I felt kind of weird
because it's not exactly the most humble
way to describe your work right nope so
I felt that like as soon as I said I
said why am I saying that this book is
awesome that's not like me I didn't walk
around go extreme ownership is the best
book ever I didn't say extreme ownership
is awesome I don't say oh listen to my
podcast it's awesome no I don't say that
I say hey you know it's if you want to
listen to it it might be interesting you
oh extreme ownership's good you know
might might might get some value out of
it I'm not running around saying I'm
awesome yeah for some
reason I said oh this book I just got
done read reading it editing it it's
awesome right so I kind of wondered why
I said that and then I realized that
while I'm reading okay so when I wrote
it right I wrote it like I was in a
10-year-old kid but that wasn't me it
was the guy that's in the book Mark he's
the character right so when I read it it
sounds like him it doesn't sound like me
it sounds like him yeah so I read the
book and I I think it's him that wrote
it this kid right right right and I
think to myself someone said how's the
book and I go man it's awesome so
yeah um that's what I realized
and but it is the kind of story that
sounds it's good to read Mark the kid
the 10-year-old
kid he's hurt right he's made fun of
can't do any pull-ups doesn't know his
times taes doesn't know how to
swim and he's getting bullied like Kenny
Williamson D you Ken you know Kenny
Williamson we all know Kenny Williamson
I'm going to post a picture K I haven't
introduced Kenny Williamson yet to the
public but I'm going to get a picture
out to him uh so he's going through all
the trials and tribulations but luckily
his uncle
Jake happens to be a big tough frog man
he's going to come and stay with him for
the summer and when oh guess what when
when Mark breaks down cuz he doesn't
tell his mom what's going on CU his mom
just is kind of you know Mom she don't
she doesn't understand she doesn't quite
you know you know what she's gonna say
oh right you'll learn that stuff she's
gonna say oh honey you're a nice boy
don't worry about that big bully he
won't bother you anymore no no my mom
actually he will right so so Mark breaks
down kind of he won't tell his mom but
then Uncle comes and his uncle's like
hey what you know we going to hang out
what are you GNA do I can't do anything
I can't swim breaks down so you know
what Uncle Jake says when Mark gets done
listing all of his problems lay on me he
says good
all those problems you got we can we can
take care of those problems those are
all solvable all we got to do is we got
to work we got to study we got to train
and that's what they do
so like I said I won't say it's awesome
but from the perspective of the kid when
you look at it if a kid wrote that you'd
say that's a pretty pretty good story
you got there and here's the deal
pre-order it on Amazon why why why
pre-order it let me tell you why
they got to print it right and they're
going to print they're going to go oh
well you know it's a kids book and kids
books don't sell very well so um you
know you just we'll print out 80 copies
or whatever you know they got their
formula yeah they got their formula
right the formula is not going to work
just like it didn't work for Jo the
formula is not going to work so the the
earlier that you pre-order it the more
they'll print the then we won't have the
shortage the scenario the masses
screaming in the streets saying give us
our book so pre-order it and that'll
take care of that while you're doing it
pick up Rap andan King Iris Chang these
will be on the jockopodcast store click
through in the book section no not the
store Joop podcast.com Joop podcast.com
books and the woman who could not forget
grab that one of course you can also
pick up you can pick up a couple copies
of extreme ownership which is the book
written by myself and Leif Babin and you
know what get a few copies and I'll tell
you why because you got to give them to
your people on the team right how many
people write to me and say I gave this
to so and so and they said thank you
yeah this is great get them all in the
game you know they need it if you didn't
have it would you want somebody to give
it to you let me ask you that question
yes you would it's going to help you out
with your game so you're going to want
them to do that and by the way if you're
if you're at your company your business
and you need some some leadership
alignment you got some little situations
going on you can check out Leif bab and
I we also we wrote a book we also have a
company called Echelon front you can
check that out that's what we do
leadership and management
consulting and that's what we do we get
companies leadership aligned and on the
same page and give them the tools to
lead and win enough said on that also
with extreme ownership we got the muster
coming muster number two May 4th and 5th
marri at Markey New York City boom yeah
yeah now you know people talk talk about
people say oh it's a game changer right
people say that sure I think and and you
usually go oh really game
chery they got a new flavor of tortilla
chips at the restaurant it's a game
changer no that's not a game changer but
description kind of the most common
description I've heard of muster number
one that we did in San Diego is game
changer dang
so people are getting after it
leadership management health jiujitsu
the good stuff of course I'm GNA be
there of course Leif Babin he's going to
be there obviously Eko Charles G to be
there JP denell you heard him on the
podcast you're going to see him there
and we none of
us none of us are going to be hiding
backstage there will not be a backstage
we're not going to be there we'll be
with you out front talking discussing
solving problems and crushing things so
come and get that May 4th and 5th and
until the mustard
while we waiting to get to the
muster you can still kick it with us
sure absolutely because we're on the
interwebs we are on Instagram we are on
Twitter as well and if you going to be
looking for that one that Facebook
boy we're on that one as well so you can
find us there Echo is at Echo Charles
and I am at Joo willink
and finally thanks to everyone for what
you do in the military and the police
and the fire department thanks to you
all for keeping us
safe and then the
workforce the Troopers around the
world creating and
building what we have making the world a
better place
thank you for what you do grinding and
pushing and making things
happen
and
again I
know that this
podcast was hard to listen to I know
that this episode
[Music]
was
disturbing and it was hard for me to
read but again to me it is a
reminder it's a reminder to all of us
that darkness is real and as I said we
cannot get lost in that darkness and we
can't let the people we know get lost in
that darkness and it's a reminder that
we have to
illuminate
that
darkness and we cannot we cannot let
evil Thrive and
permeate
permeate we can't let it permeate on a
mass
scale like Nan
King or on a personal
level like the
beautiful Iris
Chang
so get out
there get out there live your
life get after it get after it every day
go out there into the
world and
shine
so until next
time this is Eko and
Joo
[Music]
out